[Music]
[Applause]
brady quinn the former notre dame
fighting irishman
joining us on the program what did you
get for being a finalist uh for the
heisman trophy brady
uh a trip to new york and uh i got to
sit there for a while and watch someone
else get the reward now it was it was uh
like it was a good experience you got to
be around a lot of the other past greats
in college football um it's obviously an
honor just to be in consideration for it
and that's you know that's gonna be the
interesting part about this year in
listening to your discussion is
you know there really should be probably
six or seven guys that go you know they
base it technically on the bouting or
voting and that point system that they
have and how many guys get first place
second place third place votes but the
reality is it's hard to think that
there's not going to be a
you know there's probably hard to
distinguish between who you know should
be the guy this year i think
if you're looking at the best
quarterback play
that would be bryce young in my opinion
um i think he's been the best
quarterback from wire to wire even
though last week's game he struggled
mightily however he did come up when
they needed it the most
kenny pickett's the most valuable to his
team i don't know that pit's anywhere
close to playing an acc championship
game if he's not there so you could
probably make a case for him you know i
heard you talking about jordan davis and
that's probably the downside of playing
that position is as good as you can be
as a defensive tackle when you play on
the interior of the d-line it's everyone
else around you who's more often than
not going to be able to have success
since
but you're still doing your job and
you're dominant but it just doesn't get
appreciated the same way as aiden
hutchinson for example who you could
make the case as the best player in
college football with the way he's
played this year as a defensive end and
in their biggest moment you know last
week he had his heisman moment yeah as
far as three sacks 15 pressures which is
unheard of i mean you can make the case
that he's as deserving of it as anyone
um let me let me start with uh
brian kelly
um his departure i know that you being a
notre dame fighting irishman um how
could he have done it differently better
uh more tactfully
he could have waited
he literally could have just waited a
week if lsu wanted brian kelly that bad
or let me put it this way
if coach kelly wanted to leave notre
dame
the most tactful way he could have done
it is say to lsu look i want to come
there you want me
let's just put push this thing off a
week because
if we have a chance to win and it works
out this weekend where they're actually
in the college football playoffs i want
to go finish this job and try to coach
this team to a national championship and
you should want that because you should
want me to do the same thing if i'm in
that position at lsu
and and the reason why i say that is in
part four the players the coaches
everything that he was able to
accomplish during his time at notre dame
that's just the proper way to do it
and also though for lsu because he's
already done this before to cincinnati
he built them up got them to a new year
six game and then left before that bowl
game and then now he's become the
all-time winningest head coach at notre
dame and left again at a time where
you're going you could have just waited
a week to see if they're playing for it
and if look if the team was playing for
a new year six and they don't make it in
so be it no one's going to hold it
against you
but now i kind of warn lsu fans you know
he's poked around and wanting to coach
in the nfl at some point you know what
would exclude him from having a couple
great seasons at lsu which you know
they'll probably have some you know have
success and then he starts wanting to
leave to go take an nfl job i mean the
timing's a little different because the
seasons but
that's where i just say if he just would
have waited a week
i don't know that anyone would be upset
about him wanting to leave for 95
million dollars and where he feels like
he's got a better chance of winning a
national championship that's his own
prerogative but the timing at which he
did it and then the way things become
public with him telling that team hey i
think you're a top four team and then
turning around a day later and telling
you know the lsu players why he's there
and and why it's not a notre dame it
just it all seems hypocritical but
probably nothing worse than the the
southern accent that was displayed last
night at the basketball game in baton
rouge that was uh that took the cake
though i'm not sure you're ever coming
back
uh
well i don't know if you know this but
uh notre dame made it official marcus
freeman is the new head coach and we
have exclusive audio of him taking over
and you know he is embracing the culture
at notre dame ah brady i just wanted to
say it's an a it's a real pleasure and
an honor to be made the head coach of
the fighting irish see
i mean
it happened there in south bend and it
happened to uh brian kelly you know at
lsu
it's weird how it works out like that
you know you just you find yourself in
that you know that top position you feel
like you gotta assimilate and fit in and
all that but uh no i mean look i'm happy
for marcus i i think he you know not
only he'll continually get better and
better and better as a head coach i mean
he continued to improve just as a
defensive coordinator you know the
players love him you see the energy
around that place he kept everything
intact
i mean look at it how many coaches went
with brian kelly to lsu if that gives
you kind of any indication of how they
feel about notre dame the rest of the
coaches on that staff the players in
that locker room and their opportunity
moving forward
it kind of just goes to show you that
you know they they feel differently than
the head coach felt obviously leaving so
yeah the reality is
they're hoping he'll be kind of like
mike tomlin who took over who hadn't
been a head coach before but took over
at pittsburgh you know was able to win a
super bowl you know it was able to
really you know have a ton of success
since he's been there especially
relatively early i think that's the hope
there at notre dame and what you're
looking at with marcus freeman
brady will be part of fox on-site
pregame show in indianapolis on saturday
night it's iowa and michigan in the big
ten title game pre-game show starts at
seven eastern with kickoff at eight
eastern
uh watching uh last night with taysom
hill and the taysom hill experiment
i said you know you got to decide you
want to play him then go all in as as
your quarterback like you you want him
to be lamar jackson then then let's try
to make him lamar jackson but uh and
what do you make of the uh the taysom
hill experiment
well i think it's hard to make him lamar
jackson if you've got 10 other guys who
have to adapt to a completely different
style of offense i mean i don't care if
it was drew brees last year
or
jameis winston when he was starting this
year
that's a different offense than what
you're going to run with taysom hill if
you want to make him that than what
you're you know running with jameis
winston or drew brees in the past so
that's more of the difficulty is and
that's why i think you see that kind of
you need like an off season to really
adapt and adjust to that and find the
type of person now that you need at the
wide receiver tight end positions to
make it work but i i think at this point
we kind of know what taysom hill is as a
quarterback i think we know what kind of
offense they have to try to run and
in order to be successful
so
that you know i don't want to call it an
experiment you know or just whatever
decision that sean paid made at this
point i think the tough thing for them
moving forward is deciding on like what
is our quarterback situation did jameis
winston show us enough do they want to
turn it over to ian book which would be
what i would do right now and see what
he's capable of doing you drafted him
for a reason you should probably know
where you're at with every quarterback
on this roster as you head into 2022
whether that's if you're looking for a
veteran you know to trade or who would
be a free agent or if you're looking in
the draft again at one of these
quarterbacks in the first round
you better have a good feel for what
everyone's capable of doing where you're
at at that position so at this point i
think we've seen enough to kind of know
what he is and what he's not and i think
he's more valuable to their team as that
swiss army knife as opposed to you know
playing quarterback around a group
that's just not i don't think the
roster's built to play like that i think
they're more built for a pocket pass or
a drew brees at james winston if we did
a re-draft
with micah parsons so trevor lawrence
stop me where you would put micah
parsons trevor lawrence goes number one
zach wilson goes number two
trey landscape i mean i think he'd
already start there saying maybe mac
jones goes number two if it's gonna be
another quarterback taken but yeah okay
but where's micah parsons go
um
would you take him
like if you're that
atlanta with kyle pitts
uh
bengal's got a great player in jamar
chase jalen waddle has played well in
miami yeah penny sewell uh in detroit um
jc
i'll put it this way he was if you're
just looking at the overall prospects
and taking out positions
i mean he was one of without a doubt a
top five prospect
so if you're ranking it that way i mean
based on his ability to play off the
ball on the ball rush the patch all that
stuff
and he's freakishly athletic he was a
top prospect you know you would have
looked at him as you know could he help
any team that he got drafted to and
immediately have an impact and
eventually you could see him wearing a
gold jacket someday yeah and so you
could probably have stopped at the jets
at two
and said if they didn't have a huge need
at quarterback but they did so
they you really can't go that direction
there and then as you proceed to the
rest of the draft you know san francisco
could they have used them sure but they
want to go after trey lance because
maybe they feel like he's more the
future they don't want to pass up on
that so we can go through the draft but
the reality is he was probably a top
four top three prospect uh at you know
overall if you just took away all the
positions and what he had put on tape
and how he was going to test and how
he's going to segue into the nfl
why do we put designations on players
because micah parsons went from being a
linebacker to we need you as an edge
rusher and you get paid as an edge
rusher you don't get paid as a
linebacker and right i think that's
going to be interesting to watch is you
know how he's listed but micah parsons
is sort of a tj watt kind of player and
uh you know should be up there for
defensive player of the year because
this was
this is one of the worst defenses
statistically in the history of the
sport and he along with diggs and dan
quinn uh have really
made them presentable at least and at
times formidable
well you'd have to say it was a little
bit of luck i mean he started playing
off the edge like that because of
injuries yeah it wasn't necessarily
where they were originally going to put
them and that's usually how this all
works out right like tom brady ended up
in new england out of you know luck he
got trapped in the sixth round he's
turned out to be the greatest player of
all time so that's a piece of it i think
how dan quinn uses him is a part of it
too understanding his background he had
played defensive end in the past when
you saw him rush the passer at penn
state you understood he could be able to
get pressures he could get to the
quarterbacks so all those things kind of
added up to his ability to do it but you
have to have a coaching staff that's
willing to that's that's going to be
willing to look at his stature and size
and say can he still set the edge can he
still play stout on that side even
though he's not your typical you know
4-3 defensive end and what that body
style looks like so
it's a little bit of luck it's coaching
it's obviously the abilities of micah
parsons who can pick that sort of stuff
up as a young player in this league
which probably is the most impressive
thing it's just you talk about football
iq a guy who can play off the ball like
that where he was probably originally
designated to play and now he plays on
the ball and he's able to do it
flawlessly i mean it's not even like
he's hit a rookie wall or you feel like
you've had a bad game wired at wire he's
been phenomenal uh this entire season
for them so obviously you got to give
him a ton of credit too to where he's
kind of devoted himself and i don't even
play last year at penn state so maybe
you know that was part of it too he was
preparing himself
for understanding the nfl game as he was
sitting out last year
more likely to see a surprise michigan
iowa or georgia alabama
if you're if you're going to look at the
betting lines you would say alabama
because that's at least a closer spread
uh and i'd probably say alabama too just
because they've got a couple of absolute
stars i i feel i'd be remiss if i didn't
mention will anderson is being in that
conversation along with aiden hutchinson
i mean it you know will anderson's been
a part of a defense that gets
overshadowed by georgia because
georgia's been so good i mean they
remind me of like the 93 florida state
defense
if we go back that far
but
i mean
you know they're second to georgia in
almost every category for the most part
he's been a big reason why and so you
could throw his name into that list of
heisman candidates but they've got him
on one side they got bryce young on the
other
and if there's like two guys who can
really truly impact the game it's at
that edge position and it's at the
quarterback spot and bryce young makes
up for so many
of their issues up front whether
schematically on their offensive line or
just mismatches and this will be a tough
one for them you know every single week
he makes some throws and plays
that you just go no one else is really
doing this in college football and he's
only a freshman
so i think george is the team that
probably you would say
in this championship weekend
of the teams that are in contention for
the playoff is the one that you might
put on upset alert uh just because of
the stars that they have on each side of
the football alabama
great to talk to you safe travels to
indy and we'll talk to you next week
thank you brady
sounds good thanks uh brady quinn fox
sports college and nfl game analyst and
of course fox sports radio co-host two
pros and a cup of joe